today i'm going to take a few minutes to
tell you about a really innovative
cryptocurrency project called
centric centric has partnered with us on
this video
it's a video i've been excited about
publishing because centric is a project
i've been following for a while
both because of the clever concepts and
solutions they're bringing to the table
and just because of how many people are
tuning into what centric
is doing they've garnered a ton of
attention and support
from people in many sectors of the
cryptocurrency and blocks
blockchain space check out the link
underneath this video to learn more
so centric is what we would think of as
a dual token
system it's a blockchain based ecosystem
that's powered by
two different tokens the first token
is called centric rise which is
centric's main
transactional currency and its store of
value this token
is forced to continually inflate in
price over time
every hour at a growth rate written into
the centric blockchain
a year in advance by the centric
foundation the other cryptocurrency of
the centric ecosystem is centric
swap which is bought and sold on
exchanges the market
will determine the value of centric swap
tokens
centric swap provides liquidity but
importantly
centric swap is basically the network's
on and off ramp which gives users access
to centric rise
centric swap tokens are only minted
when a user deposits centric rise into
the centric smart contract so when you
buy centric swap
you're buying a claim to the centric
rise that's being deposited into that
smart contract
after the centric swap is deposited you
receive centric rise
and the swap is burned you benefit from
the ongoing growth
of the centric rise that you now own the
exchange
between rise and swap is governed by the
centric protocol that's a decentralized
immutable protocol
it self-regulates the elastic token
supply of centric swap
to meet changes in demand the protocol
is censorship resistant
and it's also independently audited in
the early stages of the centric project
centric attracts and retains new
adopters
by giving the rise token a high rate of
growth as well as hourly burn and that's
calculated by a formula in the protocol
it's triggered to burn by the smart
contract every hour
with this protocol mechanism centric
forces their decreasing supply
to meet demand through various utilities
and partnerships at this point
over 30 000 users have joined the
community it's been really impressive
how many people
are excited about the project and have
been since the early days
and the more people who join and adopt
centric centric the centric foundation
will slow down that price growth of the
rise
token probably the most exciting update
we've seen with centric lately
is their migration to binance smart
chain which took place on july 15th
after two and a half years on the tron
blockchain the tron based tokens still
function as they did before the
migration
but centric is encouraging holders to
redeem their tokens on bsc
as centric has some really cool plot
projects planned
uh on bsc but i think that this fork
to bsc says a lot about the centric
mentality and the future of the project
i really do think bsc is where centric
wants to be
at least until their native blockchain
has been developed and deployed
binance comes with the name recognition
centric is going to get a lot more
eyeballs on the project as a result of
that
and in terms of new users as well it'll
be beneficial but also
in terms of other projects they could
partner with it opens up many
technical possibilities bsc is
compatible with ethereum virtual machine
which is going to let centric take
advantage of ethereum dapps
on and on many many important things so
the way
for you to get involved is really simple
centric user
gets started by acquiring centric swap
from any trusted crypto exchange
and then like i explained you convert
your centric swap
into centric rise and from there you can
immediately benefit from the hourly
growth of rise every hour
centric rise is worth a little more
centric swap
and you can convert your rise back to
swap anytime you want and it's free to
create an account and get started
whether you want to get involved now or
not learn a bit more about what centric
has going on if you're
just someone who likes learning about
new technology and finance developments
in crypto
delve deeper into centric because they
definitely do have
several different innovations that
they've developed and put into play here
and it's been fascinating
seeing how fast centric has blown up
it's a project
i'm going to keep paying attention to
check out their white paper
follow centric on telegram and twitter
they do a really good job of staying
engaged with the community
follow the official centric blog on
their website
and for more in-depth project updates
and also amas with team members
you can find it all at centric.com i've
put the link right underneath the video
and of course i am talking about the
merits and my interest in the project
i'm not giving any financial advice
anytime you are making any kind of
financially impactful decision do your
due diligence
check with people you trust including
and up to a financial advisor if you've
engaged one
very very important to keep that in mind